You're recording private conversations with people to win like
random friend arguments. Yeah, that no I'm out. I'm out. Bye.
>> Um like they lied about the date on the transmission
of the video from me to Rose. They lied about that. They're trying
to go with some weird Google Drive theory that like well if you
send a Google Drive link once it counts as reposting it forever.
Like it's just all a bunch of like there's a vote on the floor
for this. I don't care. I don't I don't nothing is coming from
these files. Literally nothing will come. By the way, I know
for a fact that Abby said these things to people. I've talked
directly to people who spoke to Abby, right? I know for a fact
and I know that Destiny was also trying to Nothing. Never mind.
But I know for a fact that Abby did speak to people way back
then. Like that's not fake. That's not just made up. That is
something that's been independently like I've seen that
again or you like do like one response and just redirect people
to that. I think Vosch handled his stuff about as well as you
can when you have controversy. Vosch just did it like perfectly,
right? That's probably not fully cancelable controversy.
He made a statement. He made a video and then he just streamed.
He did not he didn't take like questions on it. He didn't do
anything. He just like was like, "Let's just talk. Let's just
stream normally. That's totally fine." His freak out scream of
a need to have insane levels of narrative control. Yeah, true,
man. Oh, man. Okay, we're done with coffee. I'm not sure if I
want to go. I'm not sure where I want to go here. Hold on. I'm
trying to think. Is this actually the the one? Apparently, Desi
talked more about Lauren de Lagona. Trying to >> I don't
care about the excuses. >> Let's see. Or is this the same
one from before? This might be the same one from >> But
maybe, who knows? It could be any >> Oh, here you
don't know why I was like this. >> Let's pull this up.
>> Is the timeline for the lawsuit become >> go back
to go back? What are you talking >> More clear or is it
still in limbo? The Okay, I can't ever give specifics because
it's just whenever ruling rulings are made. Okay. The three points
that I'm looking for are there's like a rare scenario if the
guy got if the dream is real that a recommendation to dismiss
it comes from the preliminary injunction hearing. That's what
we've been waiting on the ruling on for the past two months,
months, month, however long since our hearing. Okay. I don't
I thought they were a few weeks ago or last week or this week,
but maybe who knows it could be any day. We're just waiting on
it. If the recommendation isn't made then um then we have to
go >> So she's talking about the what do you call it? Uh,
I guess just a >> time for discovery. I don't know if I
don't know if I don't even know if they want to go through discovery.
Like they're dodging all of our subpoenas and requests for every
piece of information and they're not providing us with anything.
So, I don't know if maybe they're just looking for a ton of favorable
rulings here like on the last like set of motions before the
court. And if they don't get I don't think they're going to get
any rulings and I don't think that matters. I like obviously
you just have to, you know, basically put it before the court
if they're dodging subpoenas. But why hasn't there been like
a complaint? Wouldn't you formally complain or something about
dodging subpoenas to the court? Why has there been has there
been something filed saying, "Hey, they won't they won't like
address our subpoenas?" Have they brought this before the court?
It seems like you'd have to, right?
Get them. Maybe they'll just dismiss and go away. I I don't know.
Um because they're not responding to anything. So, it's either
waiting to go through.
So, it's either hopefully like like the dream would be getting
it dismissed as part of the preliminary injunction hearing and
then the um if that doesn't happen then we have to wait for our
motion for summary judgement and then if we get really unlucky
there then it's a motion for summary judgement could be anywhere
it I mean you can file it whenever but like most likely would
probably unfortunately be end of like November or December
and then if they survive motion for summary judgement then it
goes to trial in May I guess but >> and I' I've seen most
of the Laura Lawyers who've looked at this say the Abby declaration
lets them survive summary judgement,
which by the way would probably be the reason not to talk to
uh what's his name? Darius. I feel like people are just going
to try to like discredit Abby. I I feel like comes down to like
how much >> We'll see. Can't imagine it matters if it happens
on stream. It's just like >> they can Yeah, I have DMs
from Lauren saying over and over she wasn't involved with the
case at all. If you ever need them in the future, hey, if you
ever have information on that, go ahead and email me, you know.
>> Oh, I think there was Lauren De Laguna tweets, right?
that basically were saying she wasn't involved with the case
beyond uh setting up the Substack. Not sub substack, the um what
do you call it? The GoFundMe, the Give Sendo, right?
>> Oh, okay. I can't see her tweets anymore. But it's fine.
Wait, I wait. There's no way Twitter's like this.
>> Nothing. It's fine. It's fine.
Lauren's Lauren's tweets are protected and uh >> I don't
follow her, so I can't see her tweets. And if she doesn't want
them shown, I won't show them on stream. >> I just think
that she didn't help with the case at all. And we'll see. I'm
not blocked. I'm not uh she's not following.
>> I was like, "Oh, I could just go find these tweets somewhere
else, but if I if I'm not following, then probably just want
them right on stream." Okay. I don't see how. So, I've listened
to I listened to some of potentially criminals coverage the other
day, which is the lawyer, the Kiwi Farms guy who he posts in
the Kiwi Farms thread, right? Potentially criminal. Yeah. And
he he's like hyper negative on Pixie's legal representation.
But even he was like, "Oh, no. I think this easily survives summary
judgement and goes through." You said Destiny's being delusional.
Yeah, I would imagine. >> What is the downside for them
uh to dodge subpoenas? Um
the downside Well, I mean they would have to dismiss those witnesses
or be held in contempt, I guess, right?
Oh, but the um Yeah, I I I don't I don't know. Like I like the
case is like the case has been dead for a long time. Um they're
just like they're just like nibbling around the edges for random
like like I think they know that Abby is lying. I think that's
why she was freaking out publicly when she realized that they
up her redaction and then her Discord name was released because
I think she never wanted her name to be public. There's a reason
why she's dodging subpoenas and she doesn't want to be deposed
because she she's lying and they know she's lying. There's a
reason why all >> Wait, Lauren de Laguna is dodging
out publicly when she realized that they up her redaction and
then her Discord name was released cuz I think she never wanted
her name to be public. There's a reason why she's dodging subpoenas
and she doesn't >> I by the way I know for a fact that
Abby said these things to people. >> I've talked directly
to people who spoke to Abby,
>> right? I know for a fact and I know that Destiny was
also trying to Nothing. Never mind. But I know for a fact that
Abby did speak to people way back then. Like that's not fake.
That's not just made up. That is something that's been independently
like I've seen that
>> I can confirm that independently.
>> don't want to be depos because she they >> it
is why he was Yes. It's why he was like talking around to people
and they know she's lying. There's a reason why >> Yes.
Yes. Protect Destiny. No, it's uh it's so he'll see about not
knowing what it is. >> All of the witnesses somehow disappeared
or deleted their accounts and they haven't produced a single
screenshot from any of those. I don't know how you have 15 people
message you and you don't have any evidence of any of that >> Yeah,
that would be bizarre to me if they had no evidence of that.
That would be pretty silly to me
>> to not take screenshots of any of that. Be pretty uh
pretty goofy. >> Yeah. Like it's it's just they're just
like fraying that there's like >> but they haven't used
evidence from those 15 people, right? So like if you dismissed
and they couldn't produce any of that evidence, then that evidence
can't be it's not doesn't mean anything, right? Obviously.
Didn't Abby swear under oath? How can she dodge anything coming
from Destiny? I don't think she can. I think she could be compelled
to testify or be held in contempt. But but she hasn't lied about
anything. Her her testimony says, "I have contemporaneous logs
saying that I I had received these videos from Destiny and I
have screenshots of those and he's deleted his logs with me,
but I have my personal logs to him." That's what she's claimed.
And I don't think there's any reason to believe that those that
isn't true. Some Hail Mary thing that comes through. Um like
they lied about the date on the transmission of the video from
me to Rose. They lied about that. They're trying to go with some
weird Google Drive theory that like, well, if you send a Google
Drive link once, it counts as reposting it forever. Like, it's
just all a bunch of like, there's a vote on the floor for this.
I don't care. I don't I don't Nothing is coming from these FC
files. Literally, nothing will come if they probably not. All
right.
>> I just I don't know. He keeps saying that people are
lying, but like the the what do you call it? The affidavit is
totally in line with the evidence produced. So, I don't I don't
understand where the concept of lying comes in here at all. I
think he needs he probably needs somebody to like break and stop
testifying so that he can like dodge discovery, I would imagine.
>> Which, by the way, if they do discovery on Destiny,
they find he didn't send the video or they they can't recover
it. Like I don't I don't know. Like I I don't think you should
be found guilty from innuendo,
>> obviously. Right. I think he should be found guilty
of the truth. I don't know if that needs to be said. This obviously
true, though. There's one other thing. Oh, I was supposed to
watch his uh Amy Dangerfield content. Somebody linked me this.
He watches Amy Dangerfield video and then he kind of rants about
how and why he records people without their consent or knowledge
in in general >> This one is when I began in political
commentary. I made the decision that I would speak to absolutely
everyone. And I say that I mean literally
>> never mind he's anarchist. I didn't want I actually
wanted a tested my thinking not ones built from >> She's
such a though. I know. Give me two seconds. I'll be right back
cuz I'll I know it's it takes like a minute or two to get in.
She talks about like how she met Destiny. So, give me a second.
I'll be right back. >> And that's the mentality that honestly
led me to value payment and it's the mentality behind the creation
of this idea of dangerous conversations. And it was in that same
spirit that I first met. Wasn't she literally a friend of the
stream? Um, kind of friendlyish. Um, she started to get turned
on to um the like the team Farha and team Lauren though a long
time ago, which was funny because um she messaged me once asking
me to clarify something because I think Lauren had or Jasmine
had told her something that wasn't true and then we had a conversation
about I still my Instagram deals with her. We had a conversation
about it and I provided proof and I'm like, "No, these people
lie like crazy." Um, but if you remain in any social group long
enough, eventually you'll I guess you'll turn. But it's so funny
because I still have um assuming she didn't delete her account.
Wait, hold on. This whole group of friends is like insane. Everybody's
insane, dude. How does this guy just like this guy is
is it Cal Ripken? Is that who owns the uh MLB batting average
record? The most hits, most consecutive hits. This guy's Cal
Ripken. Every single hit. Every single one. They're insane. again
and again and again and again. How did he find so many insane
people? Every single person. Hold on. Hold on. Wait. They're
insane again. No way. Hold. They're insane again. There's
I wonder I wonder how Connor's feeling about, you know, at what
point does your pattern recognizing brain turn on? At what point
does your pattern recognizing brain turn on, guys?
At what point? At some point, you'd hope. But I don't know. Oh,
I don't know the point. When will my pattern matching brain turn
on, guys? I don't, dude. It seems Well,
>> Wait, Kyle Ripken at most consecutive starts. I don't
know baseball very well, unfortunately. God damn it. Oh, wait.
No, most consecutive games with a hit was Cal Ripken, wasn't
it? Oh, no. That is Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's somebody else.
Oh, okay. Lou Garri. Oh, so for finding for finding women who
are apparently all insane, he's Lou Garri. And that helps and
aligns very closely with um Lou Garri's disease and the complete
decrease in muscle mass too, like multiple hits here. >> We
had a phone call about it. Oh, and then their text messages afterwards.
So, yeah. So, I definitely still have those, but okay. All right.
Well, let's hear what what what did I >> He probably has
the phone call, too. I get the feeling that this guy's got every
single way he can communicate like >> personally do to
slight this person who I've never had a bad interaction with
or done anything bad to interpersonally ever in my entire life.
You non-consensually sent revenge for sorry you non-consentually
sent of her friend to at least one person that like is bolted
on proven probably multiple people. You recorded non-consensually
multiple of her friends, right? Or is it just is it just Far
that he recorded non-consensually in a conversation to win like
a friend argument, right? Yeah. I I think there's every reason
for all of these people to think you're out of your mind
and hate you just based on the evidence that's out there alone,
right? Obviously, there's not like crazy these people hate you.
Of course, they do. >> Let's go. >> And it's the
mentality behind the creation of this idea. And it was in that
same spirit that I first met Stephen Ben Jr., better known as
Destiny, a couple of years. >> Junior, I'm the second.
Okay. >> Now, he was one of the first major streamers to
really take me seriously, meaning he had me on his show several
times. We debated, we disagreed. Um, sometimes even a lion, surprisingly.
It's a matter of time we honestly build a rapport. You know,
we share our friendship groups, uh, group chats, we met up at
birthday parties.
>> Uh, guys, we are seven subs away from another hour on
the stream. Got 20 minutes left. Not going to take a long chill
out here, but uh, give subs, donate, TTS, whatever you got to
do if you want to keep the stream going. Okay, we we have seven
or seven subs away, I think. Yeah, seven subs away. Let's go.
>> I actually had some legitimately interesting conversations.
Everything from values to philosophy and whole group chats. We
met up at birthday. >> Holy curse.
>> Zena is the only real one. And actually, >> Zena
the queen
so far. Holy c. Oh my god. How cursed is this? Jesus.
>> I'm legitimately >> dude. How does how does just
everybody who's ever known this guy on a personal level for more
than like two years?
>> Is it just like Invader V? Like I actually start at
this point looking at Invader V and be like, "Bro, what is wrong
with you? You're like the only person the only woman who's like
known him for a long period of time who isn't. You're like the
only one, right?" >> Yeah. interesting conversations. Everything
from values to philosophy and politics and >> h you can
count Zena too. >> Despite our differences, I always thought
that there was like this mutual respect between us. Uh but then
everything changed. Everything changed. But one of our mutual
friends, another streamer who ran in our same circle, came forward
with a disturbing allegation. Her name is Pixie and she alleges
that Destiny recorded her in a private room and then sent that
footage onto somebody else who then leaked online for the entire
world to see. And she never agreed to any of this. So currently
she is pursuing legal action and according to her in a private
moment and then sent that footage onto somebody else who then
leaked online for the entire world to see and she never agreed
to any of this. So currently >> what was the catalyst for
the falling apart of that friend group? Um probably a combination.
>> It was Destiny repeatedly non-consensually recording.
Okay, he can say whatever he wants, but he basically thought
that they were like somebody was misrepresenting him. I think
he said Lauren was misrepresenting him some arguments, right?
He he had and then to prove that he was correct, he had like
pulled up recordings that they didn't know happened to show like
this is what was said to me in private actually. And apparently
according to uh a third party, not not either of these parties.
Apparently that is what made Jasmine go, "Oh ho, you guys are
insane. I don't want to be around any of this [__]
anymore. You like I'm out." You're recording You're recording
private conversations with people to win like random friend arguments.
Yeah, that no I'm out. I'm out. Bye. Farha and Lauren
>> friend group. Um, probably a combination of Farha and
Lauren. >> Combination of Far and Lauren >> would
be my guess. I don't know how far plugged in though. Lauren though
is Lauren is like a like a Kelly kind of person who she will
sit in a friend group and do work for as long as she needs to.
Though >> she is pursuing legal action
>> and according to her she is not alone. She actually
claimed that there are multiple women with similar experiences.
And for me, that was the moment. It was clearcut I walked away
from Destiny entirely. No ambiguity, no second >> We haven't
talked in a long time. She didn't walk away from I don't think
we talked for like a year before that. But >> Uh that crossed
a line that really doesn't get to be blurred. And to make matters
even worse, Destiny didn't even deny it. I actually covered this
entire situation like every single part of it on the unusual
suspects earlier this year. But honestly guys, things have gotten
crazier since then. So if you are at all interested in helping
out with Pixie's case against Destiny, there is a link to >> You're
not happy to hear that? What happened with Farha? Um, I think
I've talked about this before, haven't I? The Listen, just breaking
up with Molina just introduced a lot of complexity to my life.
Um,
>> wait, no. I thought this was Hold on.
>> Oh, I should get the full story on this from somebody
at some point, right? Crazy that his die hard fans never actually
criticize an critically analyze the idea that there might be
something wrong with him. Well, some dude, some will say like,
"No, I I like him because he's a local, right?" Some some people
are self-aware enough to know that. Other people don't recognize
it. I could have sworn he trying to show like he was trying to
show these people that they talk [__] about each
other. It was just like stirring within this friend group, right?
I I think he recorded Farah talking about Molina and played that
for like and and Lauren and played that for Lauren.
There's like a way this went that was uh I don't even know the
whole web. But it's it's just funny that there's never any responsibility
that falls on him.
>> It's very funny. Really was there. Really was there
for some of it. I don't think he's there for all of it. >> Just
breaking up with Molina just introduced a lot of complexity to
my life. Um,
without getting too deep into the weird, var was just on some
really weird like
saying different things to me and Molina in ways that were like
super sus and trying to get me and Molina to separate so that
Far could date me. Uh, in like the most like oh
it's again it's happening again. That one unfortunately I don't
really deny or like he's he's leaking it now. Uh, I'd heard this
and realistically if you think about it, Farah moved across the
country at the drop of a hat and like moved into the unit beside
him or moved into the same building, right? Like it kind of
What did you think was happening? What did you think was happening
there? Okay. It was just like really crazy bizarro sus.
Um, so was it before or after that Far was trying to break you
and Molina up that you decided you were doing Farah Fridays with
her? I forget. Was that before or after she was trying to break
you and your wife up or >> I feel like I didn't I go over
all this on stream? I feel like I did this a long time ago. I
don't want to rehash all of this like >> he's never he's
never I as far as I know he's never leaked the far wanting to
date him thing >> like um uh all this cuz it's all just
like we it's super weird and cringy interpersonal.
Um,
but like I guess so like for one um like one like one example
of this would be when it came to a um when it came to a boyfriend
that Far had like she was telling Molina how much she was like
super in love with this guy and you know like cherished him and
wanted to move down with him and blah blah blah. But then when
she would talk to me um she would like give me her phone like
oh like you should text this dude and like uh you know make him
sound stupid for this or you should do this. I'm like I don't
why you like why you just break up with this dude or whatever.
And she's like oh you know I cheat him all the time and blah
blah blah. I mean okay whatever. Jesus.
Okay. So, apparently Farhut not a virgin. All right. Who Who
called it? Who called it? Not me. I I didn't speculate cuz I
felt like it was rude, but I'm sure I feel like a lot of people
called it. Um, but yeah, it was just like like that's like one
of like 50 and there's like more like crazy weird bizarro.
>> By the way, he's got no reason. I said I didn't call
I didn't call that. Okay, that's not me. Um,
but I just find it weird. Like he's watching a video of Amy Dangerfield.
From what I know, Farra has not commented on any of this. Far
just basically like totally retreated publicly. Didn't want to
have any association with Destiny cuz she didn't want to get
any outed by Destiny. And now here he is outing that like she
around on Boyfriends and she also wanted to date him and like
what what is he gaining from leaking this stuff about Far? I
have no idea. He just sees enemies everywhere. these conspiracies
everywhere and he's just like, "Oh, there's all these people
in this friend group now. I'm going to totally malign Far, too.
>> Seems kind of like a piece of thing to do. Who would
have who would have guessed that?" Yeah. So, we So, there's just
once I had figured out the um Oh, when I feel like So, and I
don't remember what I ever said publicly about all this or not.
When Lauren de Laguna accused me of like secretly recording people
because she wanted to throw that out there. It was in regards
to a conversation that I had with um Far that I recorded so that
Molina and I could listen to it because I somebody was going
crazy here because every time I would talk to Molina then every
time I talk to Far I get like completely different stories about
everything. I'm like okay something I don't understand how I
can have the same conversation with both you and hear completely
different things. So then I recorded a conversation with Far
and then you know I was going through it with Molina. like, "Okay,
this is" and then she would show me the front like, "Okay, >> what's
the Is this the same secretly recorded conversation that happened
that got played in
Ohio for Rei and Jasmine and Lauren? Is this the same recording
or is this a different recording? Which one is this?" >> This
is like crazy. This like she's telling completely different things
to both stories or to both parties here. And that's when um that's
why when everybody used to ask me in the past like, "Oh, why
doesn't Fargo come over anymore?" That's why that separation
happened. I thought I went over this on stream or maybe I never
said this publicly. RIP. But >> do you think do you think
it's possible for a guy who keeps records like this, for a guy
who meticulously like tracks all of this stuff, who records it,
knows all of this? Do you think he doesn't know what he's gone
over on stream? >> Have fun raising platform in the description
of this video. She is fighting a battle that no one should ever
have to fight alone. But >> do you think he'd realize if
if he had or had not said Far wanted to date him on stream? Do
you think he'd know whether or not he'd cross that boundary?
And do you think he'd keep track of whether or not he'd said
Far is like not a virgin, she lies about all that. She's cheating
with a bunch of dudes. They did. Okay. Yeah, I went over all
this, I think. Okay. >> A huge surge in support of support
since going public with her story. This goes deeper than one
alleged violation. In her statement, Pixie actually outlined
how Destiny used these influence to manipulate dynamics within
futs, how he downplayed what happened, even joked about it, and
then turned mutual friends against her, her best friend at the
time. Also, for everybody saying that, like, and people say this,
I wish I could go over this with more substance um if I was allowed
to read off that transcript,
but like the honest truth is, so if you're getting sued for something.
So, one, these are like the person is asking for a high dollar
amount. Okay. So, no, she's I literally you haven't made a a
reasonable counter offer. I think he offered like I'll let you
keep your GoFundMe money. He's not made like a reasonable counter
offer, right? And again, that's that's the funny thing. They
just used the pre-trial negotiation number as like, oh, that's
what they asked for. And that's that was crazy, guys. That was
totally insane. >> Regardless, the problem is the strategy
for winning in court and the strategy for talking to the public
don't always coincide. So, the >> didn't Pixie ask for
15 million in pre-trial negotiations, in pre-lawsuit negotiations.
Those negotiations are supposed to be privileged. They're they're
like the convention is that they remain privileged.
And it basically understood that you say this is like our number
to like basically not even file a lawsuit to to walk away without
anything. And I believe they explicitly said make us a counter
offer like we don't need this. Just make a counter make a reasonable
counter offer, right? Which he didn't do. He counter offered
like I think it was like he he might have said it maybe. I think
he counter offered like you keep the GoFundMe money and we released
a joint statement saying you apologize and then he didn't make
any other offer. Right? Am I crazy? The >> is 1515.
But that's not a real number. You have to understand that. That's
not a real number. That is a number to say this is the starting
place for negotiations. It's not a real number. >> That
like there's this very naive and thing. And even you were saying
this my fan base like >> he said no to 150k. Oh, so they
asked for 150k and he said no. Okay, that seems I don't remember
that, but maybe he did. Oh, like uh guess you should just take
accountability and blah blah blah. If there's a person on one
side of this looking for $15 million, uh I'm not going to say
anything about this. like they can try to fight for and prove
every aspect of this in court. Like there's no way that I have
any. He had every By the way, and I I let Let him watch this
clip. He had the opportunity to counter offer. He did not counter
offer, right? They made no counter offer. No reasonable counter
offer. It was like, "Delete your Substack post, issue a joint
apology with me where you like apologize to me and you can keep
your GoFundMe money, which obviously she probably wouldn't be
able to keep at that point anyway, right?" That was like the
counter offer. There was no reasonable counter offer made. He
wanted to fight over this
after the public after it went public. He wanted to fight over
this and he's made he's continued to make decisions to continue
to fight over this. He easily could have gotten out of this,
right? 150k. Yeah, he absolutely would have saved more money
than that. He's not getting out of this with less than 150k in
legal bills. Not even close any navigable room to start saying
like, oh, like maybe I made a mistake here. No that they can
I'll allow them to prove every single aspect of that or they
want to sue me for like when we're talking about you know like
lifeending sums of money that's and anybody that would have that
expectation of me talking with specificity to the stuff um that
was that that she's alleging and any of the court was crazy.
Now as we've gone through the process more and then I've seen
where they're falling on things and I've see like how they things
have been filed now I'm like more comfortable with it. Right.
In the beginning, the reason why I didn't say anything with specificity
to like oh like you know do you know did anybody have consent
here or whatever is because the first part of the the honest
truth is that these are conversations happened a long time ago.
This is like 5 years ago six years after after I felt like there
was a conspiracy against me and I absolutely hated this person.
I suddenly remembered the conversations with total clarity where
I absolutely got consent guys 100%. It was when I when I thought
I was friends with them I just couldn't divine the consent. And
now that I hate them I totally I remember it clearly. It's clearly
it's come to me. It came to me in a dream >> years ago
when we recorded these videos and these were conversations in
person. And I don't want to say something with like an imperfect
recollection and then end up committing myself to some like storyline
or committing myself to some, you know, phrasing that I'm like,
"Oh, no way. I don't think that I said that." Cuz if I say anything
publicly obviously, right? Um Joanne, I guess who doesn't have
a job besides, you know, sitting her legal office watching my
streams all day throwing these things in court filings. But if
I could read off our transcript now all >> has he ever
acknowledged him telling NYSE didn't know if he had consent.
I don't know >> the stuff that Pixie was saying um under
oath does align with stuff that I remember and I would feel more
confident um if I could read it. Like for instance like I think
when they she the funnily enough I believe I think Pixie gives
three different answers in court about the agreement about us
recording stuff. I think the first thing she says is um we recorded
stuff but we agreed to not like send it around to people or whatever.
Some so something like kind of vague like that that roughly along
like yeah like just don't like send it to everybody obviously
right you don't want it to leak. Then I think the second time
I think she says um I agreed for him to only show it to his wife.
And then the third time I think she says I didn't agree for him
to send it to anybody. So I think she gives three separate answers
in the span of 1 hour. Now, if I'm being charitable to hers,
that is because she probably doesn't explicitly specifically
remember, but this like kind of align with Yeah, I'm pretty sure
like I I think they they discuss like their other partners. Like
the recollection is
okay, if I remember correctly, it's something like
why don't you know? I think it's something the recollection was
something along the lines of, okay, um yeah, it's fine if they
go to your wife. It's fine if um if like your wife sees them
cuz she shares like stuff with you, but nobody else, right? and
I will send it to my partner, nobody else. I believe that's what
their reason was. >> Wife and then the third time I think
she says I didn't agree for him to send it to anybody. So I think
she gives three separate answers in the span of 1 hour. Now if
I'm being charitable to her cuz she probably doesn't explicitly
specifically remember, but this like kind of
I would imagine that she would acknowledge the wife thing and
then say like nobody else. Basically, that's in her that's in
her testimony to this point was he said that he shared accounts
with his wife and I said if she saw it it was like fine or if
she knew it was fine. I don't even know if that was over the
or if it was over them like the fact that they were >> Yeah,
I'm pretty sure like I have like a general conversation about
recording stuff or whatever. Um and then this is like generally
um in the hearing did the judge ask you questions too? Yeah,
we were both on the SA with this like but um I mean it's it's
a long time ago, but the the idea that like I have to come out
and give some crystal clear statement like right at the beginning
of all of this like bro this is a big civil case like I'm sorry
that you're not happy that I'm not going to come out and layer
you know like all of these answers that the you know plaintiff
can use to layer their legal arguments as perfectly as they want
from that. That's actually that's insane. I also like by the
way that Amy is making this video months half a year into these
legal proceedings. She's taking every single thing the plaintiff
says at face value. She isn't evaluating any of well maybe she
will here on later on. Isn't evaluating any of the later legal
documents submitted and is doing the exact same thing that she
was on all these red pill shows when she was trying to get red
pill um you know trying to smash my everything. >> Dude,
this guy
this guy's going to leak everything about everybody. I don't
think he has I think I'm safe. I think I'm safe >> and
you know oh don't believe women and you know women lie all the
time. But now she's like team, you know, 100% woman, I guess,
cuz of however I guess were the political domino's fault. It's
hilarious. So, good job, Queen. >> I'm Erin.
>> Wait, was she Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. >> Was she right or wrong with her first belief?
Am I >> later legal documents submitted and is doing the
exact same thing that she was on all these red pill shows when
she was trying to get red pill? um you know trying to smash Myin
and everything and and you know oh don't believe women and you
know women lie all the time but now >> this stupid used
to totally be like don't believe women and women lie all the
time and now when it's me she can't even keep it up for two seconds
this stupid why couldn't you just say women lie one more time
you dumb this guy is losing it >> he's like team you know
100% woman I guess cuz of however I guess where the political
domino's fall is hilarious so good job queen >> I'm Aaron
how he downplayed what happened even joked about it and then
turned mutual funds against her best friend at the time Aaron
even while apologizing publicly and acting like he had taken
responsibility for what was done. It was a monster clause in
>> I love this too. How I'm Where am I manipulating?
I don't believe that. I I don't hate Aaron, but I don't believe
like there was some grand manipulation by Destiny of Aaron. I
don't see that. Um I don't see that in those DMs. Like it's it's
you could say it's manipulation in that he was like pretending
to feel bad and he said things that like were trying to make
the situation just be better in that moment, but I don't think
that's like specifically turning Aaron against Pixie or something.
I don't think so. >> What are these manipulations?
>> But guys, this isn't just about abuse. It's about >> like
Sorry. You can say there's a manipulation there and that he's
like acting like he's remorseful. he's saying all of the right
things to make them all feel like he's been appropriately chastised.
But like in terms of manipulating to turn Aaron against Pixie
or something, I just don't think that >> Control and the
kind of control that thrives in digital spaces where cloud is
currency and silence is protection. But despite the very clear
evidence and the public attention, none of the platforms that
have supported Destiny's career have even >> Why did you
say I don't hate Aaron? I don't know why I said that. I meant
What am I saying? Oh, I don't know. A lot of people I'm just
seeing a lot of people who are like super all in on hating Aaron.
I like Aaron. I don't know why I said I don't hate Aaron. Obviously,
I like Aaron. Um,
I don't know. I was trying to give the, you know, you know, you
do the thing to hedge like you're like, "Here's how I feel about
this person." Yeah. I don't know. Sorry. It's getting It's not
even getting late. I don't know.
>> Good question. Thank you for
>> like, think of how insane what she's saying is. So,
somebody sues you for something, you should automatically get
banned and demonetized from every >> No, obviously not.
What is she saying? >> None of the platforms that have
supported Destiny's career have even spoken out against him.
There were no bands, no demonetization,
>> Yeah, I don't think the I don't think it's appropriate
for
Listen, I think he could easily you could easily justify deplatforming
him for the I'm going to kill Queen. I'm making Jtock, whatever,
or these guys deserve to die. I'm going to try to dox them. I
think that's where you probably try to deplatform him, right?
But I don't I don't think for the legal stuff you can
you can necessarily get rid of him for that, right? He harms
society. Well, you could argue that, but I'm saying that like
the legal stuff, the legal stuff, you have to let that play out
in a legal court, right? And I don't know that YouTube would
take to litigating things that happen in a totally personal environment
that are like unrelated to his.
It's like it's tough. It's tough to know for sure. I don't know
how these platforms would speak out. I guess it happened to Dr.
Disrespect, but like think of how insane what she's saying is.
So somebody sues you for something, you should automatically
get banned and demonetized from every platform. Like damn, harm
society is extremely broad. Yeah, I'm I was reading a chat message.
>> She left like I I do think he's like harmful in some
ways, but it's like you have to weigh that against like okay,
but a lot of YouTube content probably is harmful in some ways.
You have to figure it out, right? >> The Red Pull arc,
I guess, and went completely in the other direction. Like what
the if >> anything his brand is actually only
>> No, YouTube YouTube demonetized Dr. disrespect though
the stuff that came out right he's not been found legally guilty
of anything and YouTube demonetized him >> unfortunately
this is a pattern that we have seen before where creators are
shielded by popularity and really profitability at the end of
the day this is an ecosystem we're saying >> like this
was the number one Andrew Tate defender did she change her position
on >> they are two genders get Destiny himself experienced
back in 2023 when he was in somewhat more of a base frame of
mind but disturbing content without consent somehow doesn't carry
any serious repercussions whatsoever but guys Destiny actually
sucks for many many many more reasons than the one we just covered
Over the fourth of July weekend, uh, central Texas was devastated
by black blood that have claimed dozens of lives, um, hundreds
still missing, and it has left communities devastated as prayers
and consolations poured in from all over the country. Destiny
entered the conversation as well. And what was his take? Well,
mostly just jokes about how the victims actually deserved it.
And I'm not being hypolic. Uh, this is actually what he said.
Maybe the kids weren't fit for camping near a river if they couldn't
swim, which he wrote in reference to 27 young girls at a Christian
summer camp in the >> Yeah, he's like a weirdo. Yeah, he's
a weirdo. Does she have the worst one than this was like >> he
went on to quit like a weirdo because they were using NordVPN
to get around to Texas. Now NordVPN quickly clarified that they
do not sponsor Destiny. >> Oh, I bet Lauren and Pixie begged
her to put a to put her fundraiser in here. Jesus Christ.
>> Guy is just like lizardlike like
>> They may even pursue legal action as they should because
there are documented damages on record of people canceling their
Nord subscriptions. But his response, of course it was. This
was just another joke at the company's expense as outrage grew
over his remarks. He basically
>> such a good tweet. >> Of course it was. This was
just >> This is why, by the way, this is why you don't
engage with the weird come vampire rage bait tweets, right? Cuz
he's just he's just looking to go, "Oh, look at these soy people."
And like his audience is like, "Oh, look how mad you made them.
You're so you're so epic, dude. You're so epic. You just made
all these You talked about kids or about kids dying and now you're
epic and they suck. Everyone else sucks. >> Just another
joke at the company's. >> As outrage grew over his remarks,
he basically abandoned all pretense and >> No, no, no.
He he talked about kids like just the other day to sombre. >> That's
literally what he that was the joke he did the other day. >> Just
right to read, but he says, "Don't ever forget these are the
same people you tell you back when they're laughing at urban
families being destroyed by deportation, LGBT, and kicked out
of the >> This is the firefighter round two, but this time
with kids. Uh yeah, listen, he already lost Lauren Southern over
the firefighter thing in the first place. So yeah, he's got nothing
else left to lose, right? >> And friends being murdered
in Ukraine by a genital maniac all because she's finalist to
break the inhumane machine that is mega just I don't know how
any of those things which many of us are actually really valuable
because you don't know anything about politics. You're we know
we got it >> or not by him valid points are mag right trans
of the military all of these things. How is that possibly comparable
to the death of young children? is just is living in a different
reality. But this is a pattern when Cory Comtor husband father
fighter and a Trump spoiler was during the attempt on Trump's
life in Ba Pennsylvania. Destiny called him a and >> keep
in mind my comments are way
keep in mind that he was hanging out with Lauren Southern while
this happened and this ended their friendship. Okay, that's what
I want you to keep in mind that actually Lauren Southern went
back to him after all of the after all the they went through,
right? She she went back, she was talking to him again. They
were in the same room. They're hanging out with Ashley Sinclair,
Elon Musk's baby mama. Okay.
And these tweets are what ended that friendship according to
Lauren Southern. Do I have to pull the thing again? All right.
Hold on. Where is this? Even so, as Southern tells it, even the
camaraderie, so this is about in this is about Destiny. When
in late 2024 the relationship was leaked, fans were shocked and
bewildered. From a fan perspective, it was unthinkable to consider
any kind of relationship developing between the respective folky
of two fandoms so diametrically opposed to Southerns and Destiny's.
But in Southern's telling, having both grown up in the digital
panopticon and served as the avatar for huge fan communities,
they had a surprising amount in common. Even so, as Southern
tells it, even the camaraderie occasioned by their shared experience
of life in the digital fishbowl eventually fell victim to the
relentless incentive to take ever more polarized positions. In
a scene surely too out there to be fabricated, she recounts her
final showdown with Banell as taking place on the night Donald
Trump was shot in the apartment of Southern's friend, MAGA influencer
Ashley Stlair, who was then pregnant with Elon Musk's baby. Benel
made several provocative posts about the assassination attempt
which prompted a bitter stand-up row and the irreparable rupture
of their friendship. Her sorrow is is palpable. I'd come here
hoping for more for clarity about my work, about the internet,
maybe even about whether I still had a friend. But now I just
felt more fractured than before, more alone. Everything felt
impossibly.
Where is this from? This is from Lauren's book. Well, sorry.
This is actually from an article on Lauren's book, but the the
actual story is from Lauren's book. That doesn't say he was there,
right? Uh
Banel is taking place on the night in the apartment. >> Lucas
head donated $3. The Tory is okay to be shot at a rally, but
not Lauren because she lets him lick come off her >> Absolutely
disgusting post. Okay. I wish you hadn't done that, Lucas, but
thank you for the $3. I cannot really answer that. Gross. Gross.
Gross. Gross. Gross. Gross. Gross. Gross.
Just gross. Uh, let's see here. Okay. I think he I think it sounds
like he was there. Uh, Banel. So, Fi, she recounts her final
showdown with Banell as taking place on the night Donald Trump
was shot in the apartment of her southern's friend Ma influencer
Ashley Sinclair, who was pregnant with Elon Musk's baby. Banell
made several pro provocative posts about the assassination attempt,
which prompted a bitter stand-up row and reparable rupture of
their friendship. I think they were there in the apartment. Why
would it take place in the apartment? I guess it could have been
online that they were doing this, right? I'd come here hoping
for clarity about my work, about the internet, maybe even about
whether I still had a friend. I feel like they were meeting up
in real life. No, I'd come here. I They probably fought on Twitter.
Maybe. I guess it does say Does it say that it happened? Does
it say that the showdown happened on Twitter? I can't remember
if she posted going back at him or not. This is It's unclear.
It sounds like he's there, but realistically, wasn't he streaming
while he was doing this? Come here. is in the internet, not in
the room. I'd come here hoping for clarity about my work, about
the internet, maybe even about whether I still had a friend.
I think it's unclear from this. It's funny you would debs
so hardcore, but moment your allegations came out, she posted
in her discord she wants nothing to do with you and hard ban
for any Jtock fans. Loloodles devs
the deb I don't know what the Can we get the English here? Who's
devs?
>> Is that possibly Zena?
I think that's a drunk person typing Zena. And I thought the
Zena I actually can't tell. The Zena stuff happened before anything
about me came out. And I don't know. Okay.
Obviously, I feel perfectly comfortable with my actions. So maybe
come here also mean or maybe come here could also mean Lauren's
friendship with Destiny. Yeah. I don't I don't even know. I literally
don't know. It's actually about the internet. Maybe even whether
I still had a friend. I Yeah, I don't know what this is actually
suggesting. Maybe she was just talking to Ashley Sinclair. This
is This actually feels incredibly Either way, the tweets were
what did it? He fought with her on a Twitter space about the
Jan 5th stuff. What? When? After this says this is the last time
they talked what Zena stuff um Zena said she didn't want to talk
to me when um but that was like before anything with Cherry came
out. So, but I for I think it had something to do with Darius
stuff. I have no idea. Wait, when was the when was the Twitter
space stuff then? Destiny Lauren had a talk about the UK race
after those tweets. So, idk. Okay. All right, maybe this is just
not true then. Damn. I hope it's true because then I hope it's
true. When is the Twitter space in time? Twitter space was like
the day after his tweet about the firefighter. What was the combo
like? Wait, hold on. What was the combo like? Let's check this
out. >> Hey everyone, >> this is Lauren >> room.
They're willing to chat. So >> with the trajectory of political
his campaign before he entered the white >> maybe if you
didn't come to speak about BLM, you don't have to you don't have
to speak about it.
When is when does Lauren Southern come >> and then Lauren
Southern >> it's like so I mean I documents you were saying
that >> instigators from getting to them that >> okay
I I completely agree with >> oh yeah the then that that
story is just like completely wrong like she just made this up
if this was the last time Wait hold on wait I don't showdown
with about bro I don't even know this is super confusing now
why did she put this in her book if this is like not true at
all That's crazy. That's a That's a rough one. Okay. Is that
Tide Pod Day? Might have been
>> All right. Base >> nicer than the Trump crowds.
Okay. I just think the guy's these guys literally believe that
God sent the bullet into this dude's skull. All >> That
he was having fun in hell with Ashley Babbot, the woman by capital
police in January 6. Um, now this did actually lead to some repercussions.
His account was banned from kick. Uh, but it gets worse. He once
argued that if Trump won in 2024, drone strikes on mega protesters
would be justified and necessary. There's evidently a playbook
here guys. Dehumaniz. >> Did I say that? That drone strike
really makes you think, huh? >> Hey, I'm just saying. Wait,
what was the what is the context? >> I'm trying to be specific
about stuff intellect hyperbolize things and >> outrage
and then retreat behind irony. That's all. But when the followers
cultivate actually start believing performance and echoing the
cruelty, it
>> Uh, what if the person who wrote that summary didn't
read a bite? Yeah, that's possible. Entire >> this is where
it becomes culture. So what we're witnessing isn't just personal
decline. It is psychological. It's a political radicalization
in real time. Honestly, studies from Harvard and UC Berkeley
actually show how social media driven political content actually
rewires the brain. Constant exposure to tribal conflict activates
fear centers and dulls empathy. But over time, people don't just
disagree. They see ideological opponents as existential threats
to their existence as less than a human. Psychologists actually
call this moral disengagement. Um that's what >> certainly
she's not a massive Trump supporter thinking this, right? >> Let
somebody essentially laugh a justify abuse and then call it righteous
clarity for the following. And Destiny, in my opinion, he's become
one of the clearest examples that I've ever seen of that transformation.
This is someone who I believe used to be relatively sane. This
is someone who once stood for debate, logic, critical thought.
And now he weaponizes trauma for clout and calls cruelty realism.
It's not realism. It's not activism. It is ego. And the tragedy
is that he's built a following on the myth that he's the rational
one. He's above the prey. But cruy, an irrational person justifies
harm to women, amongst the dead, or loss grief to win arguments.
So ultimately, guys, >> I Yeah, I don't know. Okay. isn't
about disagreements. This is >> Yeah, it's like uh clearly
I just don't think this person is very smart. It's >> about
dehumanization. That's what he's doing. Pixie's case isn't just
about >> There are some good There are some good gems here
though. The whole like recording far without her knowing about
it thing. >> What happened to her? It's about to continue
to happen for years. >> What's silence just literally making
public post and tweeting about it? What are you talking about?
>> About the so-called allies you heard away about the
platform culture that ultimately rewarded it all. So if you think
this is an isolated incident, it's not. This is what happens
when platforms reward outrage, ignore ethics, and when creators
become untouchable because they are profitable. When a fan base
>> kind of literally built her career, she tried to build
like an online platform off of defending Tate >> defends
the indefensible because they mistake charisma. That's what's
happening here. Now, I want to round out the segment by saying
that what Pixie is doing takes courage. But this whole thing
isn't just about her lawsuit. It's about whether we finally draw
a line, whether we hold people accountable even when it's inconvenient,
even when they wear the mask of intellect. And Destiny, the true,
this is just drama. It's performative. hyperbole, >> the
mask of intellect. So, not only have they stolen the aesthetic
of like rationality, now they're fighting me on now they have
the aesthetic of talking about the aesthetic of rationality.
What >> none of that matters is when the truth lands and
the mips, there won't be any arguments left to win. There will
only be accountability and that's what is not just the pixie.
>> There's a Willie video yet? Nah, I'm good.
Yeah, I have no idea. I said there there's some interesting parts
there about the um again he just consistently refers to him recording
conversations without consent. Kind of odd.